If we were designing the coffee maker as a whole and not just the software
controllers for it, we would now spec out each of the devices we just listed.
Fortunately, the hardware team has taken care of that task and
we have been given a Java API for the hardware. The API is available to
you from the class resources page. It comprises methods and constant values.
The methods provide a way of determining the status of the hardware device and
to change them as requested. The constants give symbolic names to the inner,
to integer values that, are needed by the controllers. Note that
Robert Martin wrote this example before enums were added to the Java language.
So he had to define them using the integer constants himself.